- So good morning,
and welcome to IND 3325
Zero-Downtime at Scale:
Migrating Peacock's Global
Streaming to Amazon EKS.
So my name's Ian.
I'm an AWS Principal Solution Architect.
And joining me here today
from NBCUniversal/Sky,
Director of Global
Platform Engineering, Mans,
NBCUniversal/Sky Head of
Platform Infrastructure,
Pete, and my colleague
here from AWS, Manish,
Senior Head Technical Account Manager.
So I don't know if you've
worked in technology
for maybe a few weeks, a
few months, a few years,
but I think you'll realize that
migrating anything at scale
to like Kubernetes clusters
at scale to Amazon EKS
doesn't come without its challenges.
So after a short reel,
I'll hand you over to Mans
to talk to you about how Global Streaming
were able to achieve this.
♪ Get out of (indistinct) ♪
- [Announcer] The NBA
is streaming on Peacock.
140 games, Peacock NBA Monday,
Coast 2 Coast Tuesday,
and one every 2026.
♪ (indistinct) to see this ♪
- [Announcer] Plus all new ways
to see more than the score.
♪ You know I got the score ♪
- [Announcer] From the
court to the culture,
the NBA is on Peacock.
♪ (indistinct) get out
of the (indistinct) ♪
- Thank you, everyone. Thank you, Ian.
So first, great to be here in Vegas.
Just wanted to welcome everyone,
especially on behalf of AWS,
but also Pete and I from
NBCUniversal and Sky.
So I'm gonna give you all
just a very high level view
about what we call Global
Streaming Technology,
which is essentially an engineering team
that spans across,
effectively, two companies.
So that's NBCUniversal and Sky.
So just to give you a little
bit more kind of context.
So currently, we have over
40 million customers here
for Peacock, which hopefully
everyone's aware of,
that's in the US.
But we also have other propositions
in Europe and in Africa,
which I'll talk about in a second.
So we consider ourselves,
obviously Prime might disagree with us,
but we consider ourselves
one of the leaders
in live sports here in the
US but also across Europe.
And hopefully, most of you sports fans
will know we've got,
obviously, got major deals
with the NBA, NFL, Premier League,
and recently announced the MLB.
One of our biggest events we had,
I think it was a year and a half ago,
and that was a wild card game
where we accounted for over
30% of the US bandwidth,
which is a huge achievement.
A little bit more about GS in
terms of where we're based.
So we've got kind of engineers
based here in the US,
in the UK, also across Czech
Republic, Portugal, and India.
So we are a truly global team.
So just talk a little bit
about our kind of
infrastructure and our stacks.
So multi-tenancy is absolutely
core to the way we work,
and that's not just from an
infrastructure perspective,
but also from a front end.
So if you look at the
diagram on the right,
we cover four propositions
using a single codebase,
both from a front-end perspective
but also from an infrastructure,
which Pete will go through in a second.
So from left to right, we have Peacock,
here in the US, we have SkyShowtime,
which is a joint venture
between ourselves and Paramount,
mostly in Europe.
We've got Showmax, which
is another joint venture
between us and MultiChoice in Africa.
And then finally, we have
the NOW, the WOW brand,
which is a streaming service
in Italy, Germany, UK,
Austria, and Republic of Ireland.
So as you can see,
we have one single codebase
from our front-end as I said,
but we also, the key for us
is a homogenous infrastructure
layer that, again,
covers all of those
different propositions,
whatever regions we are
in around the world.
For us, because of scale,
we really wanna maintain consistency
across all of our development teams,
and that's really important for us.
The reason, the main reason for that
is how fast we want to move.
And as I said, we have
one central platform team,
which Pete, to my right, manages,
which he'll talk through in a second.
So the problem statement
and what we're here to talk about.
So if you look at the left,
the platform team or the
platform engineering team,
right now, we spend around 70% of our time
on what we consider kind
of development tasks,
and over 30%, which is kind of BAU toil.
So an example could be
a Kubernetes upgrade,
a security patch, the
ones we all love to do.
And what we want to do is
obviously bring that down.
If you look to the right,
because it's such a uber,
multi-tenant Kubernetes cluster,
we have hundreds of
different development teams
across multiple time zones.
And if you look at the graph,
the number of deployments we do day to day
is only just growing.
So the key for us is,
how do we free up more engineering time
for Pete and his team from
a development perspective?
But at the same time,
what we cannot do is disrupt
our development teams,
especially when talking about, you know,
thousands and thousands of, obviously,
different names, spaces, and components
that are running absolutely
critical services
for those propositions I mentioned.
So I'm now gonna hand you over to Pete
who's gonna talk about
the migration strategy
and the planning and how we got there.
- Perfect. Thanks, Mans.
So platform engineering is the
cornerstone of infrastructure
for Global Streaming.
And we really focus on
trying to take away the work
that engineering teams
ultimately don't need to do
or, in often cases,
don't really want to do.
So we really want to focus on pulling
a lot of that heavy lifting away from them
so that we can do that for
those engineering teams.
So I look after the platform
engineering department
across Global Streaming.
So really, what we're focusing on doing
is doing that heavy lifting
for the engineering teams.
So what I now want to
do is sort of focus on
four key principles that
we have as a department,
and link that to how we
approach the EKS migration.
So the first principle,
engineers are our customers.
So what we really try and do,
and this is really one
of the key methodologies
of platform engineering is,
is we want to internally market ourselves.
Engineering teams should actually
want to use our products.
It shouldn't just be a case of
they have to use our products
because they happen to be
plugged into our platform.
The second, protect the
customer interfaces.
So we have an obligation to limit
the number of changes that
we make on our platform
because we can't just
suddenly make a change
to an important interface that many,
if not hundreds or thousands,
of developers are plugged into.
We suddenly make a change to that
purely because there's
a technical evolution.
We should be focusing on moving slowly
in terms of interfaces,
but rapidly advancing our technology
that we're using under the hood.
Third, deliver capabilities,
not technology.
So this is really doubling
down on that aspect.
We don't simply want
to deliver a technology
that may be the latest greatest tech
that might come out of the industry.
We want to really
understand how our customer,
and when I say customer, in my case,
that means development teams
are going to use those products.
So we want to work backwards
from how we think they're going to use it,
and then we leverage the
technology under the hood
to offer that.
And finally, reliable by design.
So as Mans already said,
we support market leading
streaming services globally.
So even a few seconds of
downtime just isn't acceptable.
So taking those four key principles in,
and I want to sort of explain to you
how we approached the
EKS migration project.
So before I delve into
it, you might be thinking,
why are we talking about
an EKS migration in 2025?
And I'm gonna give you a bit
of history as to why that is.
But before I jump into that,
when we were first looking at EKS,
we could have really taken
two traditional paths.
We could have either said,
look, this is a significant change,
we're gonna build a brand
new version of our platform,
and we're then gonna ask
all of those development
teams to shift over.
That's not really doing the heavy lifting.
Alternatively, we could
have said, you know what?
Our platform's working,
let's just leave it as is,
and let's hope everything
continues to work.
We were really tasked to
do something in the middle,
which was quite daunting for us as a team.
It was pretty scary.
But I'm gonna run through
how we approached that
and some of the lessons
learned that we had.
So just to give you a bit of history.
So we started using Kubernetes
right at the inception.
So this is pre-V1 Kubernetes.
So back in sort of 2014, 2015.
We as a department,
and we were quite a
small team at this point,
we were exposed to a lot of bugs,
a lot of issues in Kubernetes
that we were really sort of contributing
back to the community
and Kubernetes codebase,
and we learnt fast.
But one of the key takeaways that we took
from that really early
adoption of Kubernetes
was the controller pattern,
and understanding the value
of eventual consistency
and being able to declaratively
define what state you want
and have controllers that will
continually validate that state.
So I could go in,
I could change the environment
that I'm deploying to,
and we'd have controllers that
would then go and reset that.
It's quite different to sort
of things like Terraform
where you would sort of do a one shot.
This is something that we
continually want to validate.
So that's something that
was really embedded early on
in our development of Kubernetes.
But we were given quite an
extensive period of many years
of being able to really refine
and hone in our
understanding of Kubernetes.
EKS was then launched in 2017, 2018.
But that was an issue for us.
We would've wanted to
immediately pivot to EKS
at that point.
However, Peacock came along,
and kind of changed the
game a little bit for us.
Our scale shifted from
a small user base within
things like NOW proposition
and Sky Go over to Peacock in the US.
We were increasing orders of magnitude
on the number of customers,
the number of developers,
the number, the amount of
focus that we had on us
as a platform engineering team.
So over the succeeding few years,
we then really tried as much as we could
to focus on the EKS development.
And thankfully, at the end of 2024,
we actually launched our first
EKS-based streaming platform,
which was Showmax, which
is one of the propositions
that Mans spoke about earlier.
But what we then needed to
do is look backwards and go,
how do we now take our platform
that we've honed and built
over the last 10 years
and, fundamentally, a lot of
significant streaming platforms
are now integrated with,
how do we now take that
and move it to EKS?
So just to give you a bit more detail
as to what happened for us
throughout that same time period.
So you can see on this graph here,
we had a a few years of
fairly comfortable growth.
It was great.
We were able to really
lean into our testing,
our automation.
We were able to really hone in
on ensuring that our Kubernetes platform
was reliable and stable.
And I think we really fulfilled on that.
But you can see just after
that EKS platform was released,
we then had a surge in
usage on our platform.
So how do we approach this?
This is essentially what we ended up with.
So this is what we were tasked to migrate
at a really high level.
So I'm sure anyone who's
done sort of Kubernetes
the hard way will have seen
a similar pattern as this.
You'd use things like Terraform,
Ansible built on top of the AWS API, EC2,
NLBs, ELBs, all that other good stuff.
So I think we had a
pretty mature platform,
but it wasn't managed.
This was very, very much self-managed,
doing it the hard way.
We also had a number of engineering teams
and a huge amount of business units.
So we had over a thousand
developers consuming our platform.
We had hundreds of business units.
These are all disparate business units,
different organizations,
different ways of working,
different management structures.
So there's not sort of one
single individual or strategy
that we could say we're gonna now
suddenly shift over to EKS.
This is a significantly diverse
set of individuals and teams
that were using our platform.
But the key part is 1,600 apps.
This is really what we
wanted to drill into.
'Cause this is, from the tech perspective,
let's ignore the sort of business side.
Let's ignore the team side.
We just needed to move 1,600 apps
from doing it the hard
way Kubernetes to EKS.
So let's take the sort
of simplistic approach.
So going back to that initial,
you've got the two options.
You either build fresh and
then ask everyone to move,
or you leave the status quo.
We were never gonna leave the status quo.
We knew we needed to evolve the platform.
So let's maybe hone in
on that first option.
So if we were to build a
new platform based on EKS
and we took, let's say, an
average of two weeks per app,
which is probably some
apps significantly longer,
probably a few less,
but let's just assume it's two weeks,
that that would give you
61 full-time engineers
working on that for a whole year.
That's a significant investment.
And when we really take a step back
for the engineering teams,
they don't really care, right?
It's really the platform engineering team
that wants to move to EKS.
It's less the development teams.
They really just wanna focus
on developing their apps,
building their apps,
releasing new features.
They don't want to be
focusing on moving to EKS.
Going back to what Mans was talking about
on that left-hand side,
it was my team that was feeling
the pinch of self-managed.
We saw the increasing level of BAU,
but we were thinking about
shifting that responsibility
onto development teams.
This isn't doing the heavy
lifting, so let's remove that.
That's not really an option for us.
So these were the five
objectives that we laid out,
and this links back to
those four principles
that we have as a department.
So the first objective, no
action for development teams.
We offer interfaces,
and it's a pretty extensible interface,
and it's a mature interface.
In this case, kube control
and the Kubernetes API.
That doesn't need to change,
that's how they deploy their app.
We should keep that consistent.
Two, migration must be done live.
We don't have periods
where we can just simply switch
off our streaming platform.
People always want to stream
their favorite shows and live events.
Three, zero downtime.
So as with our principles,
even a few seconds downtime
just isn't acceptable.
Four, less than 12 months to complete.
So this was really something
that was largely driven
by us as a platform engineering team.
We weren't really given the timeline.
'Cause ultimately, from
Mans's perspective,
he was happy enough with self-managed,
wasn't massively happy
with the increasing burden
of the operational overhead,
but we, as a team, felt
that we were being held back
in being able to evolve our platform.
So we were hearing about Karpenter,
and all of these additional
add-ons and auto mode,
and all these features
that we couldn't utilize.
And we were seeing the
industry constantly evolve,
if not rapidly moving forward.
And we weren't able to leverage that
and offer that to the business.
So we internally said,
12 months, full stop,
let's move to EKS and
let's make it happen.
And lastly, and this is really
the gold standard for us.
Teams shouldn't even know it's happened.
So this is the gold standard.
We want to revolutionize our technology
whilst keeping our capability consistent.
We want to be in and out
without anyone even knowing.
So I'm now gonna hand over to Ian
who's gonna talk about the partnership
that we had with AWS to make this happen.
- Yeah, thanks Pete.
Okay, so as an AWS solution architect,
it's really my responsibility
to help the customer
with complex migration planning.
And I think over the last eight years,
we've really been able to
build sort of confidence
that we can help the customer
to achieve their outcomes.
So every day, we talk about Kubernetes,
every day, we're talking about
AWS services and features,
but for this, it was a
little bit different.
I mean, we needed to
talk about the tooling
as well as the services
that would help with
the migration process.
So we were able to do this,
but also we were able to talk
about proven architectural patterns
that would help the customer.
And we've taken that right across
a different sort of set of industries
of how customers have approached
large scale migration.
I mean this was really good.
So we were then able to bring
some of our solution
architect specialists,
some of our service teams
in to validate the approach,
to validate the migration plan.
And I think that was really useful.
So it's all of the right
experts at the right time
that were really able
to help the customer.
And actually, right from
the delivery of Peacock,
we'd always worked with the
AWS well-architected framework.
And that had been really useful.
Not just as a sort of simple checklist,
but actually a way for the customer
to validate the existing architecture,
but to really look into the future,
look around the corner a little bit,
and perhaps look at scale,
to look at redundancy,
resiliency, reliability,
and, of course, cost
is a big part of this.
But having done all of this,
we were able to help the customer
to just validate the approach,
to feel comfortable that
they were able to migrate.
So when they were actually
ready to make the decision
to migrate to Amazon EKS,
I mean we felt like we
had all the relationships
across the business.
We felt that we had the
relationships with AWS.
So like when they were good to go,
we were ready to really step
up and help the migration.
So then if we move into
the migration phase,
we really started to
double down on the tooling
and also the AWS services.
And then we spent a long time really
just completely validating the approach.
And actually, Pete and his team
built out a six-stage migration process.
And I think what was really
great about this is actually
they ensured that every single step
kind of like moved it
forward and validated
and tested everything they needed to do.
But if you've worked in
technology for a long time,
you realize that actually
being able to step backwards
and restore operational
state is absolutely critical.
So it's great when things go well,
but also, you want to plan
to restore operational state
when they don't.
So we really started to double down
on some of the key services
like Velero with Amazon S3
for handling the Kubernetes
backup and restore.
And Amazon EKS for now managing
the Kubernetes clusters,
Kafka for processing
messages, Route 53 for DNS.
I think what was really
critical was observability.
So for the customer to observe
the existing Kubernetes infrastructure,
but also to observe the
transition to Amazon EKS,
just to ensure that, as
the transition was moving,
it was migrating across,
that the customers were
having the experience
that they should be.
And actually, we'll come onto this later
in the presentation.
Manish will cover AWS enterprise's support
in underpinning the migration.
And, but now, I'll hand
you back to Pete to discuss
how Global Streaming went
through the migration process.
Thanks, Pete.
- Thanks, Ian.
So I'm now gonna go into a bit more detail
as to how we did the migration.
So this is really a view
of a slightly more
detailed pictorial diagram
of that Ansible, Terraform
cluster that we started with.
So again, it probably looks
similar to a lot of customers
who are using self-manager or even EKS.
So in this diagram we've got
our different integration
points into Kubernetes.
That's our CI/CD tooling.
That's gonna be a developer Kube Cuddle,
all of our CDNs,
and any third parties
that are integrating into the platform.
But the important part is
that we control that route in.
That's key for how we did this migration.
And also key was the fact
we had quite an opinionated platform
and how applications
deployed into the cluster.
Again, that was a really key part
in having this be a possibility
for how we did this migration.
So the first step for us
was fairly self-explanatory.
So spin up that new EKS cluster.
This is in the new, in the same VPC,
same egress NAT,
so that any traffic
coming out of this cluster
looks and presents as if it's
the same self-managed cluster.
And that sort of simplifies
things like firewalling
and fun stuff like that.
Create a new Route 53 zone.
And this applications can
still present themselves
as the same Layer 7
route into the cluster.
But the important part here
is we didn't want to delegate
that zone via the parent zone.
Step two.
And as in, touched on,
and this was something that
we worked closely with AWS on
because we really wanted to know,
surely other customers have
done a similar migration.
'Cause it can't be that
unheard of, of moving
from turnkey, do-it-yourself
Kubernetes to EKS.
And Velero was the defacto
choice for doing this.
But again, it's a technology,
not really a capability.
We needed to build a lot
of automation around it.
But the first phase was
to really shift across
those core services.
So that's things like
CoreDNS, Ingress monitoring.
I wish we had EKS add-ons for this,
but we had to do a lot
of hand-cranking here.
And then the next stage was
to shift over the application workloads.
And this is where we started
to step a little bit further
into the application team space.
Previously, we would've always said
anything at the namespace level
is for the development teams to manage.
We, as a platform engineering team,
that is not our responsibility.
That is the development
team's responsibility.
But this is where we really needed
to question that for this migration.
At this point, we stepped
into the application space.
We had to do a lot of
understanding in that space.
We needed to understand every application.
I'll go into a bit of detail later on
on some of the more complex applications
we needed to migrate.
But we needed to really understand that
and then shift it across.
Because we are, suddenly,
as part of this migration,
taking on a lot of accountability
in terms of the reliability
and availability of those services.
And then step four is delegate DNS.
So this migration that we performed
was a big bang migration.
It was something that
we had to do full stack.
We could not do service by service
because a lot of our architecture
is based on things like
Kubernetes Service Discovery
and service routing.
So it means we couldn't
just shift over one app
because any downstream apps
may still not be up in that new cluster.
So we needed to see the full stack
in that cluster move over.
And then lastly, and
probably the easy bit,
and the very satisfying bit for sure,
was to get rid of the old cluster.
These are clusters dating back to 2014,
which really was testament to the team
that we were able to
continually upgrade patch,
and actually take tech from 2014
and make it relevant for 2023, 2024,
which is when we were doing this.
But yeah, it was sad
to see some of them go,
but ultimately, it was
better for the future,
and we were able to leverage
a lot more out of EKS now.
So I'm gonna go into that
six stage migration process
that Ian touched on
because what was key for us
is to really lean on automation
and controllers to do this migration.
We could not rely on humans sitting there
manually moving apps from
one side to the other
at the scale we were running at.
It just wouldn't be safe,
and it also wouldn't take us 12 months.
So the first step was
pre-flight validation.
So this is really where we look at things
like Route 53 zone TTLs.
We wanted to massively reduce those TTLs
to give us more flexibility
in being able to flick over
to the new region or new cluster.
And then if anything does go
wrong, we can pull it back.
But this was something
we did weeks in advance
to ensure that all clients
have that new, fresh TTL set.
Next was building the EKS cluster.
So alongside all of the clusters,
we also deployed a dedicated
end-to-end test suite
that we developed as
part of this migration.
I'll go into a bit of
detail in a moment on that.
And also, all of the Velero mechanics.
So the plugging in with S3,
and all of the other stuff
that we needed to set up
in both the self-managed
clusters and the EKS clusters.
At this point,
we're now ready to start
taking a snapshot using Velero
of that self-managed cluster.
But we obviously need to stop
any incoming changes into the cluster.
Thankfully, because we have a
fairly opinionated platform,
we were able to centrally
disable pipelines
across all of our development teams
to essentially stop
them making any changes.
That would then allow us to
take that snapshot into Velero
and start the migration.
This is really the first time
that developers might have been
aware of something going on,
but you'll be surprised
as to the amount of
messages we actually got.
It was fairly minimal.
People weren't really aware
that this was happening.
Now, we've got the big stuff,
this is where it's really
starting to kick off.
So this is where we did
that workload migration,
and we decided to do a 50-50 scale up.
So this allowed us to
scale down our self-managed
and up on EKS, partly for cost,
but also we want to ensure
that there are certain issues
that may arise by having two
larger scaled applications,
talking to some of the persistence layers.
Again, I'll talk about that in a second.
Stage five.
So this is really where we start to see
traffic moving over to the new clusters.
So this is where we do
the zone delegation,
and then we bring that EKS
cluster fully up to 100%,
and we bring the
self-managed clusters down.
And lastly, we re-enable the pipelines.
So this stage process,
so really from stages three to six,
which is really where development teams
may be aware that something is happening.
This is something that will
happen in a matter of hours.
This is single-day
activities that will be done
so that we can do it quite quickly.
We want to be able to take snapshots,
and we don't want to be blocking teams
from making development changes.
Because as Mans said at the beginning,
there are a significant
amount of deployments
and changes continually
going into production.
We couldn't afford to
take down the environments
for too long.
So I'm now gonna drill into two key areas
that I think were absolutely critical
for the success of this project.
So the first is our test suite.
So this is really the makeup
of the different aspects of testing
that we had across our migration.
And some of these test
suites remain even today
and we leave in the environments.
But I'm gonna step through a few of them
just to give you an a sense as
to what we were focusing on,
some of the key performance indicators
that we wanted to drill into
as part of the migration.
So the first is around
synthetic load testing.
So we want to continually
know what is the latency,
what is the availability at a P99, P99.5
across the entire platform at load.
This isn't a functional test,
this is continually injecting
load into our platform
so that we have very reliable data
to tell us if there's
something wrong on the client.
But also, you'll notice this
is a service that we own
as a platform engineering team.
So we also have reliable
data on the server side.
So we manage the entire
journey from request,
all the way down to response.
Two, zone validation.
So I already touched on earlier around
the fact that we have new
zones that are created for EKS,
but they're not delegated.
So we've taken on the accountability
to make sure that those
services are running,
but dev teams can't access them.
They don't know how to
access these new pods
that are suddenly running in EKS.
So we had to take ownership
of functionally testing
those applications.
We weren't doing full-scale load tests,
I don't think they'd be
particularly happy about that.
But we were doing very
low level functional tests
to ensure that things like
all of their pods were up,
that they were responding
to health checks,
that they were having a
certain level of latency
that that we were getting
the right percentage
of 2x, 3x, 4x, 5x,
and we were doing continual comparison
between our self-managed
clusters and our EKS clusters.
So we were able to look at those metrics,
and essentially look at deltas
between the two clusters.
So even if an app has a
significant amount of 204s
or a significant amount of 404s
because of the way that the
application's configured
or really the nature of the app,
we would be able to compare
and validate that there is no difference
between self-managed and EKS.
Next is node and cluster level checks.
So again, we want to make sure
that all of our nodes are healthy.
We have a lot of services
that run on them,
and we want to be able to run
node and cluster level checks continually.
And lastly, and this was
something that I think
was probably the scariest for us,
and it's something that
we couldn't really manage,
and that is files that we don't own.
So we felt that the most likely cause
of an incident or an
issue with this migration
would not be our firewalls
because we've managed those,
and we can essentially do all
the due diligence around that.
But it's, if any other team has a firewall
that maybe only allows
a certain /26 or /28,
that, potentially, we weren't aware of,
we can't validate everyone's firewall.
So what we did was, rather
than look at those firewalls
and reach out to all of those teams
'cause we sent the comms out,
but was to lean more on VPC
flow logs and CloudWatch.
So we would look at
any anomalies in spikes
in potential dropped connections
or anything essentially changing
between what we expect on our self-managed
versus what we see on our EKS.
This was really key,
and we did pick up quite a few issues here
where we were seeing significant numbers
of packets being dropped
coming out of our platform,
which indicated a firewall issue.
And underpinning all of
this is VictoriaMetrics.
So the scale that we run at,
we could not simply rely on
something like Prometheus
or even really Thanos.
We needed something more distributed
that could scale to the
size that we needed.
So this was absolutely critical
in us being able to do
this type of analysis.
So the next area I want to zoom into
is our workload migration.
So I touched on it a moment ago
around some of the more complex workloads,
and I think the majority of
our applications are stateless.
So pretty easy to migrate.
There were some issues,
but generally speaking,
we were moving stateless workloads from A
to stateless workloads in B.
Where it became a little
bit more difficult
is this example you can see here.
So we have a number of services
that use things like Kafka for queuing,
and being able to have some level
of producer and consumer
type architecture.
The problem we had here
was that a lot of the Kafka clusters
that we configure
have a set number of
producers and consumers
defined on the cluster itself.
So if we, as a platform team,
suddenly doubled the number
of consumers and producers,
that could significantly affect
the performance of Kafka,
and we could get additional number of,
essentially degrades that Kafka cluster.
So what we needed to do
was essentially take a
more fine-tuned approach
to things like Kafka.
You can see in that diagram
that I was sharing a second ago,
we had to shift over by a
delta of plus or minus one.
So where we took a
consumer and producer pair,
we increased in EKS, we
reduced in Kubernetes.
Again, this isn't something
that we did one off,
we had to build automation to do this
for a number of use cases
across across the board.
But it was something that
we worked really closely
with a lot of our Kafka experts
across Global Streaming.
But it was definitely
the more complex issues
that we actually hit.
But thankfully, we were able
to sort of get through that.
You'll also notice in that diagram
that multi-region was key.
So what we needed to do
was actually shift some
of our traffic away
from the environment
that we were migrating,
and wait for the queues
to essentially get to zero
before we perform that migration.
I do appreciate a lot of organizations
don't have multi-region,
and we also have certain propositions
that are not multi-region.
So the way that we approached that
was really focused on really
quiet periods of the day
to ensure that those queues
are as close to zero as we can.
And thankfully, we didn't
hit any issues at that point.
So where did we get to
in that 12-month target,
which is pretty ambitious at the start?
So we essentially spent six months
not migrating any cluster.
Whenever I was giving an update,
it would say I haven't
done a single cluster yet,
which wasn't particularly great
when I was reporting up to Mans and co.
We weren't migrating
clusters at that point,
but we really had the
confidence and backing
of Mans and the team to,
he knew that we were developing
a lot of tools and automation
to be able to rapidly migrate to EKS.
So we spent really six months building
that six-stage process
that I just ran through.
And we finally migrated our
first cluster at the end of Q2,
which was kind of our internal target.
But what we then were able to do
over the succeeding six
months, and really four months,
was migrate the entirety of
Global Streaming in four months.
And that was all down to that automation
and that testing that we'd built.
And we had next to zero
incidents or issues
with this migration.
And that was because of the due diligence
that we really put in.
And I also really want to highlight
some of the support that we had
from Ian and Manish and team.
We had a lot of support from AWS with this
to ensure that a lot of the right people
and the support was around us.
And I'm sure Manish is gonna go
into a bit more detail
on that in a second.
So what's the key takeaway?
'Cause it's not really just
about Kubernetes, to be honest.
We're not gonna be doing an EKS
migration again, thankfully.
But the real unsung hero
here was an interface,
a declarative way of
defining what you want
with your platform engineering team.
So what we're now looking to try and do
is pivot as much of what we offer
as a platform engineering team
away from a plethora of APIs or interfaces
or GitHub repos or all
of that other stuff.
And we want to build a
declarative interface and spec
the teams and our customers,
our internal customers,
can declare what they want
so that today is their
workloads in Kubernetes.
But we're currently working
on being able to define
things like Keyspaces,
any other database
technology you might have,
CDN configuration.
Really, the options are limitless.
And when I look at things
like AWS controllers
for Kubernetes or ACK,
and a lot of other tools out there,
this is really where we're seeing
the platform engineering industry going,
and we're really trying to keep pace
and ensure that we can
offer that same interface
for our developers
across Global Streaming.
So I'm now gonna hand over to Manish
who's gonna go into some
of the support he gave us.
- Okay. Thanks, Pete.
And hello, everyone.
As Global Streaming's
technical account manager,
I would like to highlight
how we are building operational excellence
for Global Streaming,
as well as how AWS Enterprise Support
help facilitate this migration.
But before we do that,
could we have a quick
show of hands, please?
How many of you are AWS
Enterprise Support customers?
All right, fairly good mix. Thank you.
For those who are unaware,
let me quickly talk about
two key AWS Enterprise Support engagements
that were directly linked
with this migration.
So NBC Universal and Sky
are AWS Enterprise Support customers,
which means that they get access
to a designated technical
account manager like me
who works closely with the team.
Through Enterprise Support,
we have built a technical
partnership with the team.
This also means that they
get access to AWS expertise
whenever they need it,
whether it's for
architectural discussions,
technical deep dives or
operational challenges.
For this migration,
we had our AWS Countdown
initiated for the migration.
So what we did was we worked
in parallel with the customer team,
and we collated all the
important information
around their AWS environment.
And then we had our AWS experts
look into the internal run books
against the AWS services
involved in the migration
and come up with a detailed,
specific technical recommendations.
In the next slide,
we will look how AWS Countdown
on helping this migration,
but the real success story here
is how Global Streaming team
has leveraged all of
these support mechanisms
to make sure they meet their
project migration goals.
They take our inputs whenever valuable,
but always maintain clear ownership
of the technical decisions.
So let's look into the
timeline once again.
Pete has shared
this is what the project
timeline looked like.
The project got kicked off in January,
and soon after, AWS
Countdown was initiated.
Through the information we collated,
we knew that AWS Amazon EKS
is at the front and
center of this migration.
So this prompted a very good
technical discussion point
with the team.
The team has been managing
the self-managed Kubernetes cluster.
But with Amazon EKS,
the control plane became
the managed offering.
So we discussed with the team
around the best practices
of the observability
for the control plane.
What are the key metrics that
get exposed via CloudWatch?
And for this migration specifically,
what are the specific metrics to look for
to make sure that the
control plane is healthy?
Similarly, we also had a
discussion with the team
around the control plane scaling aspect.
There was already a good
public blog post around it,
like around how Amazon
EKS control plane scales
in response to various inputs and metrics.
But for this specific technical migration,
we discussed with the team
around what are the specific steps
to take care of so that
the platform scales
in response to their migration.
And last but not least,
before the first progression
cluster migration,
we had heightened AWS awareness.
So, which meant that in
case if anything goes wrong
during the migration
and if there is a need
for AWS support case to be logged in,
the support case engineer who is working
on that support case gets
the context of the migration
very, very quickly
so that they can help the
customer efficiently and quickly.
Through the rigorous testing,
the proactive planning discussions,
and this heightened AWS awareness,
the project went smoothly
without any issues.
Now, in the last slide for this section,
I just want to highlight like
what does the life look
like after the migration.
So operationally,
we are seeing already the
benefits after this migration,
tracking the Kubernetes version
has become very, very easy.
Upgrade process has
become very smooth now.
So this means that engineers are
spending time more on innovation
rather than maintenance.
Through our technical discussions,
we also continue to discuss
with engineering team
around various optimization opportunities.
For example, we are already
talking with the team
around Karpenter for more
efficient node scaling,
as well as Provisioned Control
Plane scaling, and much more.
Now, all of these technical
discussions happen organically
through our Enterprise
Support partnership.
And at last, we are also exploring
the different AWS native
services across compute,
networking, database
to add more resilience into
the platform capabilities.
With this, I'll hand it back to Mans
to talk about specific
improvement metrics that we see,
that we are seeing after the migration.
- Thank you, Manish.
Hopefully everyone's
still awake in the back.
By the way, you all look super cool.
It looks like a scene out of "Tron"
via futuristic pink headset,
so it looks amazing.
I'd love to take a photo later,
but yeah, that's one for later.
So I'm gonna, now that
I've given Pete 12 months
for this project, what's the benefit?
What do we actually get out of this?
So let's have a look.
So that pie chart I showed
you at the beginning
where we had 30% as a reminder
of kind of what we consider BAU toil,
it's now dropped down to 10%.
So that's just a reminder.
That's things like upgrades,
and security patches,
and other things we love to hate.
So the benefit of that is obviously
50,000 fewer lines of
code that we've just,
you know, thrown away, which is great.
Our upgrades are now six
times faster with EKS,
obviously that's a huge benefit.
But what does that actually
mean for us in reality?
So what what it means is
that we can now accelerate
what we consider development.
So things like, you know,
rolling out Istio, and
Karpenter, and Argo.
It's not to say we couldn't have done that
without this migration,
but it's allowed us to accelerate it
and do more in parallel with that.
Ultimately, that's the benefit
that we've, so, you know,
great work to Pete and the team,
and obviously massive
help, and thank you to AWS.
But yeah, I mean obviously that it's,
we could not have done that obviously
without this great partnership.
So yeah, thank you.
I'm now gonna hand it over to Ian
who's got some questions for all of us,
so over to you, Ian.
- All right. Thanks, Mans.
So because it's a silent session today,
it's really hard for us to
do a traditional Q and A.
So we actually were able
to talk amongst ourselves
and do more like a FAQ.
So what we thought would
really resonate with you
are questions that we probably
thought that you would ask.
But we will be hanging around
for a few minutes after the session
if you wanna come and speak to us,
and then, of course,
you're welcome to do so.
So first question for Mans.
So, Mans, how has the Amazon EKS migration
transformed Peacock's ability
to deliver major live events
like the Super Bowl, Super
Bowl and the Olympics?
- Thank you, Ian.
So yeah, I mean as you can imagine
there's a lot less for
Pete and his team to do
in terms of, you know,
whether that's scaling,
whether that's testing.
And, you know, like I said,
things like support, it's a lot easier.
We also get the benefits
of the new features
that Amazon will roll out via EKS.
But it's actually a lot more than EKS,
and what we are looking to do
is kind of transform how, you know,
how we work with kind of managed services,
like things like Keyspaces as well.
Yes, we have obviously large
events like the Super Bowl,
and the NFL coming up,
but that the key for us is obviously
that the growth kind of internationally.
And I could easily get a call tomorrow
from my boss saying we've
landed another deal,
another partnership with
another streaming service,
and we've got another 12
months to do a migration.
So I think it's more about the mindset
and the tooling that we've
built as part of this
that's ultimately, you know, given us
that great option going forwards.
- Yeah, brilliant. Thanks, Mans.
And I think, Pete, over to you,
you mentioned earlier in your presentation
that you're hoping to expand
the migration approach
maybe to, from Kubernetes,
but maybe to like database
or content delivery networking
or something like this.
So can you tell us a
little bit more about that?
That'd be great.
- Yeah, sure.
So as I sort of touched
on in the presentation,
I think the key for us is ensuring
that we follow a declarative way,
not just for application deployment
but for all aspects of
the developer ecosystem
and lifecycle.
And I think traditionally
what we've needed to do
is build our own controllers.
- Yeah.
- And we have a set of
engineers within the team
that this is really something,
that's their bread and butter
is to be able to build those controllers.
And we've built a number
of them over the years,
and this is pre-CoreDNS.
We were building controllers
to manage Route 53 zone delegation
through the Ingress resource
and all of that other stuff.
Obviously, now the industry
really is leaning in
to the declarative-controller-based
eventual consistency.
And I think we are really excited to see
what's coming out of, in particular, AWS.
So I think tools such as ACK or KROs,
AWS controllers for Kubernetes,
I think are gonna be game changing for us,
and that we can just use that.
And I know it was actually
announced a couple of days ago,
the fact that that's now
gonna be an EKS capability
that we can just enable,
as well as things like Argo CDs
is just totally game changing for us.
But if I pivot back to
things like Keyspaces
and CDN configuration,
I think we, right now,
are actively working
on building controllers and
contributing to controllers
to be able to manage those aspects of the,
essentially, the ecosystem.
But the important part for us
is making sure that the
way that is declared
is not technology specific.
It needs to be declaring
what the developer wants
from that aspect, whether
it is a relational database
or whether it is the ability
to expose their app on a CDN
or add in caching,
it should not be related to
the technology under the hood.
So that in the future,
if we need to go and move
to a different technology
or a different CDN or we
want to expose more CDNs,
we don't need to then
go and ask 1,600, 1,800,
however many developers that we may have,
to go and make those
changes on their codebase.
That data's there,
we can make that change on
the platform engineering side.
- Yeah, and I think, you know, look,
I think that's super interesting,
and I think probably
the people here today,
and I think perhaps in the future,
I'm sure you'll talk about it again,
but I think it's a really
interesting approach
that I think people can
really benefit from.
And it kind of leads me nicely
onto the next question for Manish.
So, Manish, have you observed
similar migration needs
among other AWS customers
in the way that Global Streaming
have migrated to Amazon EKS?
- Yes, in fact we do.
Like we do see other customers
going through similar migration journey,
but they all do in isolation,
because I appreciate there is not a lot
of publicly referenceable
documentation at this moment
around these kind of journeys.
So I'm really grateful
that Global Streaming
is sharing the journey
with the wider audience.
And I'm hoping that we can follow it up
with probably like a further
white paper or a blog post
so that we can distribute
it with the wider audience
- Yeah, I mean, now, look,
I think from my perspective,
there's a lot from people to learn from
like yourself, Mans and Pete.
I think what you've done
here is really interesting
and kinda like super cool.
I think if we can blog
about it in the future
or perhaps a customer use case,
I think that I, you know,
I think people would
really appreciate that.
So changing track a little bit now,
as Peacock expands, Mans,
how's the modernized infrastructure
supported your overall growth strategy?
- Yeah, I think speed to
market is absolutely key.
And, you know, like I said,
we could easily, you know,
sign a deal with a
another streaming service,
you know, in a matter of days
and given another 12 months.
So I think speed to market,
and rather us having to provision
and write a lot of our
own infrastructure code
is using managed service.
Whether that's persistence,
whether that's CDN,
whether that's actual
Kubernetes clusters itself,
I think it just gives
us that speed of market.
Key for us is a lot of these
new kind of partnerships
that we're making
are kind of global.
- Yeah.
- So, you know, we could get
a call, you know, next week
to say that we've signed a
deal with someone in Asia
or in Australia or in South America.
So I think absolutely key
is the speed to market,
and we only really get that by using
more and more kind of managed
services with yourselves.
- Yeah, I think that's amazing.
And I think obviously speed to
market really counts, right?
So Pete, just a quick another
question for yourself.
You talked about your team's approach
to testing and automation.
I know we talked about
Application Recovery Controller
and Fault Injection Simulator,
and these kind of technologies.
How are you testing recovery capabilities
and resilience for live sports again,
like the Super Bowl or the Olympics?
- Yeah, I think you can probably
tell testing and automation
is like at the heart
of like my department.
It's something that we
all pride ourselves in,
and it's always the
first thing that we ask
whenever starting any new project.
And that also means that
it's built into our culture.
So when we look at our platform,
we're constantly looking at ways
that we can further validate,
and essentially break our platform
or find those particular breaking points.
And I think something like
AWS Fault Injection Service
or FIS has been really valuable.
We've been heavily using that
over the last sort of 12 months
or so.
- Yeah.
- Since it got launched.
And that really allows
us to validate things
like zonal failures or regional failovers,
all these sorts of things.
That's absolutely key.
But I think another tool,
and I know you mentioned it as well,
is the AWS Recovery Controller.
What we're now looking to do,
and this is really only possible
via us being able to
free up that BAU time,
is we want to now pivot
towards being able to be
totally regional tolerant.
So we want to be able to
use something like ARC
to fully fall over to a different region.
But alongside that, things
like chaos engineering
and chaos testing within
the Kubernetes cluster
is again something that we really want
to sort of try and focus on and build.
We don't want to have all of
the testing and automation
that we did as part of
this migration lost.
We want to continue evolving that.
It shouldn't just be
a one shot.
- Yeah.
- This has to just be something
that we continually lean into
for essentially ensuring that things
like the Peacock Super
Bowl actually works.
- Yeah, I mean certainly,
we're hoping that is the case for sure.
I think that kind of segues now.
So Manish, what preparations
are being prioritized
to ensure the optimal view experience
for large scale events?
- Yes, so as Pete said,
like the teams across Global
Streaming do rigorous testing
in preparation for all of
these big live event games.
So what we have been recommending
to the team is to go for,
like another engagement
within AWS Enterprise Support,
which is AWS Countdown Premium.
So it gives you much more support
while doing these testing phases.
So our recommendation has been
to get this Countdown Premium
at the start of your testing life cycle.
So that whichever designated
engineer is coming in,
they have more context
around the live event games,
your scale, anything that
you hit on the roadblocks
so they're aware.
So that when the big day comes,
everything has been tested.
Every AWS, there is heightened
AWS support awareness
so that there is nothing
that could go wrong
on the day of the main live events.
- Yeah, thanks, Manish.
I think that's absolutely critical.
So I think we've got time for
perhaps one last question.
- So let me throw a question
back at you, I guess, Ian.
So obviously I've touched on
kind of our global ambition,
and obviously not just
kind of global reach,
so kind of a lot of things
we wanna do with Gen AI
and kind of the features,
but can you give, I guess, all of us,
kind of an insight into
what you have in your world
over the next couple of years
that will kind of help us
push towards that next stage
in terms of our ambitions globally?
- Yeah, I mean I think
that's a really good question
for where we are at re:Invent, right?
So I think we're seeing new services
and features sign up every day.
I think it was really,
I think we're really relieved
to see Amazon EKS
Provisioned Control Plane
turn up as a pre-invent item.
I think that's helped us out quite a bit.
But look, I think we
have a roundup next week.
I think there's so much
to come from re:Invent,
and obviously I'd encourage you now
to attend as many sessions
as possible like this,
but also a lot of the
service announcements.
And then I think the same
for everyone here today.
You know, I really encourage
you to get out there,
really make the most of re:Invent,
and really look at all of the new services
and features that are now being
released on a daily basis.
So I think with that now,
we will close the session.
And, but I'd really, really like
to thank Mans and Pete for their time
and for their partnership.
I think I hope you found
the story of their journey
to Amazon as EKS as inspiring as we do.
And look, I'd encourage you
to get out there for
the rest of re:Invent.
Really enjoy your time here,
and thank you so much today
for your time and attention.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, everyone.
- Thanks.